[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 23 mai bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez pour cette
édition du 7 8 journal de tv 60,18 voici
les titres
une journée de sensibilisation
handisport elle se déroulait aujourd'hui
au lycée dumont-d'urville à maurepas en
présence d'athlètes paralympiques rendez
vous organisé par la classe mca g2s
diplôme tout récent sur l'animation et
la gestion de projet sportif
c'est le challenge robotique de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ski robe
revient pour une quatrième édition au
prisme d'elancourt les 27 et 28 mai
mille enfants et adolescents devront
relever le défi robotique et cinéma et
de cinéma il en sera une dernière fois
question à la fin de ce journal tomber
de rideau sur notre chronique spéciale
festival de cannes ce soir l'yvelinois
guillaume canet à la fiche de la belle
époque et les étudiants de 3e à
elancourt qui découvrent la croisette
on prend tout de suite la direction de
guyancourt le laboratoire latmos
spécialisé dans l'observation de
l'atmosphère et spatiales fêtait
aujourd'hui ses 10 ans avec ses
partenaires au programme de cette
journée des conférences une visite des
lieux et des stands retraçant les
différentes missions spatiales et futurs
projets du site on écoute le directeur
du latmos au micro de michael et demi
d'euros ici voilà on a sorti finalement
tout ce qui est fait les prototypes et
des instruments des copies d'instruments
qui ont été dans l'espace et qui montre
du coup toute la technologie qu'on
développe dans le cadre du laboratoire
mais ça représente aujourd'hui
dix missions spatiales qui tourne autour
de la terre ou qui sont partis explorer
le système solaire et dans lequel le
laboratoire où était à l'origine du
concept ou créer un instrument ou ea en
charge l'analyse opérationnelle des
damnés et d'autres événements seront
organisés tout au long de l'année dans
la structure le latmos ouvrira notamment
ses portes au public ce sera le 21
septembre pour arrêt des journées du
patrimoine une journée de
sensibilisation aux handisports elle a
eu lieu aujourd'hui au lycée dumont
d'urville de maurepas une manifestation
à l'initiative d'une classe en mention
complémentaire animation et gestion de
projets dans le secteur sportif les îles
saint lô notamment qu à tester à des
vélos adaptés aux personnes handicapées
alors pour en parler pour revenir sur
cette journée trois invités autour de la
table benoît de garder bon soir bonsoir
vous êtes professeur d'économie gestion
au lycée dumont-d'urville de maurepas
eric garraud bonsoir bonsoir professeur
de ps également pour cet établissement
et killian bouillot mon soir quand ça
vous a été élèves de cette classe mca
g2s qui veut dire donc mention
complémentaire animation et gestion
c'est une formation qui a été ouverte à
la rentrée 2010 8 on va en parler dans
un instant déjà un petit bilan sur cette
journée c'était une première pour le
lycée dumont-d'urville est ce que c'est
une journée qui a intéressé les élèves
les élèves du lycée
c'est une première et du coup on
pourrait dire une première concluante
puisque du coup toute la journée on a eu
beaucoup de lycéens qui sont venus
notamment sa partie du matin sur les
stands du coup tester du coup les
différents vélo qui était mis à leur
disposition plus l'après-midi avec
deux interventions de l'athlète
paralympique et on a vu du coup voilà un
lycée voilà si vous un jour nouveau avec
beaucoup d'élèves intéressés et du coup
voilà sur ce point là on peut dire que
ça a été amplement réussie mais pourquoi
cet intéressant l'intérêt de l'organiser
justement cette journée même vous pour
vos cours de ps en quoi c'était
complémentaires finalement avec une
année de travail au sein du ministère
que c'est vrai ça rentrait tout à fait
dans le cadre de la la formation
initiale c'est qu'effectivement cette
année c'est la première année sur le
l'académie on a on a été choisi le lycée
dumont d'urville et le lycée norgay pour
reprendre en main donc cette cette
formation toute nouvelle donc on dise eu
un peu les plâtres et donc l'objectif de
cette formation c'est c'est d'aboutir à
des ddd projet donc là le projet de du
groupe concerné c'était de de
sensibiliser nos élèves lycéens à cette
histoire du handicap qui prend de plus
en plus d'ailleurs qu'il est le thème du
handisport esquissé choisi assez
facilement c'est ça a été une évidence
pour vous à leurs débuts
au mois de janvier je crois on a
commencé à parler d' organiser un projet
au sein du lycée
du coup on a commencé à lister les idées
qu'on avait et au final en pesant le
poids le compte parmi toutes les idées
on n'a vu qu'une journée de
sensibilisation handisport était la
meilleure c'est une thématique pour ce
dont on ne parle pas c'est forcément
dans les médias au sein aussi d'un
parcours scolaire
c'est pour ça qu'il fallait la mettre en
avant aujourd'hui et alors il y avait
notamment plusieurs animations des
ateliers proposés où l'on se mettait
dans la peau d'une personne en situation
de handicap
l'objectif là clairement c'était de
changer les regards sur sur le handicap
déjà c'était donc d'échanger notamment
du coup avec du coup les demandes des
associations qui sont venus avec leur
matériel
donc je remercie vraiment du cool
c'était mort pas levé ses skis et
l'éclair handisport six ans de faim s'il
n'avait pas été là on aurait pas eu ce
matériel effectivement c'était vraiment
de changer les regards se mettre à la
place de ces personnes handicapées et de
se dire que finalement même avec un
handicap ont pu réussir à faire du sport
et nous voulons vraiment montrer et ils
ont eu aussi vu les difficultés qui
pouvaient rencontrer
du coup jour le jour dans leur pratique
dans leur pratique sportive et on a vu
enfin ils ont vu aussi du coup la
volonté l'envi de vos coups de réussir
dans ses différences par des rencontres
notamment avec deux athlètes
paralympiques trésor makunda et bofa
qu'on dise que c'était des rencontres
enrichissantes
cet après midi ça fait effectivement pas
ce qu'ils ont fait part de leur
expérience
et puis ce que je tenais à préciser
c'est qu'effectivement ça ça
correspondait tout à fait à la formation
puisque dans l'année on a eu la
la chance de pouvoir visiter des publics
différents
ça rentre dans le cadre aussi savoir on
est allé en ehpad on est allé à la mgen
on a même fait un tour au lycée toulouse
lautrec donc spécialisé justement dans
le handisport saint-lys fait et c'est
vrai que aboutir à un projet c'est vrai
comme celui là c'était c'était l'idéal
serait une façon de conclure l'année
très positive est un projet mené par
cette classe mc alger 2 est ce un
dernier mot avec vous kilian donc c'est
une première en france inquiet un
diplôme créé par deux ministères de
l'éducation nationale et du sport
pourquoi vous vous êtes inscrits à cette
formation qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire ensuite
alors moi au tout début je ne voulais
enfin j'étais pas vraiment
dans cette idée d'être dans dans le
monde sportif
en fait je voulais être comédien du coup
avant j'avais fait des études à evry en
arts du spectacle
puis j'ai voulu continuer dans ce sens
sauf que je n'ai pas été pris et en je
me suis dit en quoi je suis bon aussi le
sport du coup je suis venu ici et du
coup sans regret et pour la suite je
m'arrête ici au niveau des études j'ai
commencé à travailler dans l'animation
du coup je reste à peu près dans le
thème dans un centre de loisirs et on
arrive déjà à la fin de cet entretien en
tout cas on pourra retrouver un
reportage complet sur cette journée du
handisport demain dans l'émission 7 8
l'hebdo merci à d'être passé son plateau
la suite à présent de nos trois
questions aux candidats aux européennes
élections au parlement de bruxelles et
strasbourg se tient ce dimanche en
france 34 listes en lice pour ce scrutin
parmi elles deux bouts la france qui
répond aux questions de patrick jacques
de dixmude parce que nicolas dupont
aignan qui conduit notre liste se bat
depuis 20 ans pour alerter dénoncé dans
la droite ligne de la filiation de
philippe seguin sur les dangers de ce
modèle-là de construction européenne de
cette union européenne technocratique
bureaucratiques qui est ruineuse pour
les peuples et notamment pour la france
et que donc
nicolas dupont aignan a toujours été
très visionnaire sur tout ce qu'il a
dénoncé ce sur quoi il a alerté et
aujourd'hui et bien tout ce qui se
produit nous l'avions prédit prévu cette
union européenne que l'on nous fait
volontairement amalgamé avec l'europe
mais qui n'est pas l'europe
cette union européenne qui est donc la
structure supranationale basé à
bruxelles technocratique
antidémocratique puisque né le 1
commission européenne à bruxelles banque
centrale européenne cour européenne de
justice cette organisation nous pensons
donc qu'il faut la sortir de l'europe il
faut sortir l'union européenne de
l'europe et revenir à une construction
européenne à un modèle qui ne soit pas
un modèle ultra libéral qui ne soit pas
soumis à des intérêts étrangers à
washington à berlin
soumis à la chine union européenne qui a
échoué sur tous les tableaux qui n'a
rien construit aucun grand projet nous
n'avons pas été capables ils n'ont pas
été capables de bâtir des concurrents
aux gars femmes par exemple dans le
numérique alors c'est un enjeu essentiel
[Musique]
le défi majeur c'est vraiment de
renverser la table à bruxelles et à
strasbourg pour faire en sorte que
l'europe
enfin se préoccuper résolvent les grands
enjeux qui sont devant nous c'est à dire
l'emploi la relocalisation de deux
millions d'emplois pour stopper ce libre
échange fous ces politiques d'austérité
et de libre échange intégral qui sans
cesse détruisent nos normes sociales
environnementales sanitaires en laissant
rentrer n'importe quel produit depuis
les états unis ou la chine dans des
marchés où ici nous interdisons à nos
propres industries ou agriculteurs de
produire de cette manière par exemple la
première chose que nous ferons c'est de
bloquer le budget de l'union européenne
car nous voulons que la france ne donne
plus 11 milliards nets jeudi bien-être
c'est à dire elle en donne 22 milliards
tous les ans elle en récupère 11 inclus
la pac d'ailleurs nous voulons revenir
au niveau
de monsieur chirac à l'époque nous
donnions 2 milliards d'euros à l'union
européenne
[Musique]
et puis c'est une nouvelle candidature
pour ce mouvement après les législatives
de 2010 est le parti animalistes conduit
également une liste pour ce scrutin des
européennes il défend la cause des
animaux
trois questions posées une nouvelle fois
par patrick jacques de dixmude voter
pour le parti né ma liste d'une part
pour changer le sort des animaux aux
européennes d'autre part redonner espoir
aux jeunes qui sont aujourd'hui blasé
par l'ensemble des politiques et on le
voit clairement sur le terrain lors des
tractages aujourd'hui les jeunes se
reconnaissent plus dans les programmes
politiques traditionnels et le parti
d'humaniste propose un programme
vraiment différent je voudrais citer
alphonse de lamartine
on n'a pas de coeur un pour les animaux
et un pour les humains on a un coeur on
en a pas
[Musique]
le parti animalistes fait partie d'un
groupe de onze partis animalistes en
europe et nous partageons un programme
politique commun 248 mesures qui vont
permettre d'améliorer le sort des
animaux en europe on parle de l'ensemble
des animaux aussi bien terrestres et
aquatiques dont il parle aussi bien des
animaux de compagnie on est contre eux
et qui ment l'abandon et on veut
justement que les abandons d'animaux de
compagnie soit puni on parle également
des animaux élevés des animaux élevage
d'élevage
je rappelle aujourd'hui que l'élevage
intensif est la première cause du
réchauffement climatique
donc en s'occupant justement des animaux
non humains on s'occupe également des
animaux humains et qui dit animalistes
dit humaniste nous sommes inclusif et
non exclusifs comme autre mesure
interdire la détention des animaux dans
les cirques m'interdire des traditions
telles que la tauromachie ou le gavage
des oies dans toutes ces mesures nous
souhaitons justement qu'elle soit menée
par l'europe car nous savons qu'en
france rien ne bouge
et rien ne viendra de la france 89 % des
français considèrent que la cause
animale qu'il cause importante c'est un
sondage ifop de février 2010 9 lors des
élections européennes il y à plus de 60
% d'électeurs qui s'abstiennent de voter
si nous sommes capables aujourd'hui de
mobiliser ces abstentionnistes qui se
reconnaissent dans la cause animale qui
concerne la cause animale est une cause
prioritaire importante et bien nous les
appelons justement à voter on est
aujourd'hui pour les animaux tous
rassemblés pour défendre cette cause
donc aujourd'hui le parti animalistes il
défend une cause il défend pas une
couleur politique
on propose un vrai programme différent
on propose une approche différente et on
espère que les jeunes si on fait un
résultat important se décideront à se
réengager en politique
[Musique]
et l'ensemble de nos trois questions aux
candidats aux européennes à retrouver
sur notre site internet tv 78 points
comme c'est le challenge de codage et de
robotique de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ski robe revient pour une quatrième
édition ces lundi et mardi prochains au
prisme d'elancourt le thème cette année
la robotique et cinéma mille élèves du
bassin d'éducation seront présents de la
maternelle au lycée on en parle avec mes
invités autour de la table geoffroy et
grève bonsoir directeur général adjoint
à la proximité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines alexandra de
plex bonsoir vous êtes conseillère
pédagogique de l'éducation nationale au
numérique sur le bassin de saint quentin
en yvelines
emmanuel chapron bonsoir vous êtes
professeur de mathématiques au collège
paul eluard d'elancourt vous avez
participé à ce ski robe avec vos deux
élèves qui sont ici c'est lilian et
evans soir à vous qu'on vous donnera la
parole tout à l'heure vous allez nous
parler un petit peu de ce robot que vous
avez amené ici en plateau a déjà une
première question avec vous alexandra de
plex le principe de ce trophée
quel est il alors si surtout un
challenge en fait où des équipes de la
maternelle au lycée vont venir présenter
le parcours de leurs robots qu'ils ont
étudiés toute l'année puisque ils ont
toute l'année c'est un projet vraiment
annuel qui sollicitent encore beaucoup
de de compétences de leur part et donc
le 27 et 28 juin prochains sur les deux
journées cette année c'est la première
fois là on est en quatrième édition du
challenge mais c'est la première fois
qu'on fait deux journées de consécutive
parce qu'on a beaucoup de classe et
beaucoup d'intérêt de la part des élèves
et donc ils vont venir pour présenter le
parcours le parcours est imposée sur le
thème du cinéma
cette année donc ils vont
nous présenter leurs robots et est ce
qu'ils ont fait ou non plus en plein
festival de cannes donc le thème est
d'actualité geoffroy greffe pourquoi
l'organiser quelle est la politique sur
le numérique de saint quentin en
yvelines est ce que ça va avec cette
politique justement ce trophée oui tout
à fait alors effectivement ce challenge
vous disiez à 4 ans d'existence il a été
impulsée au départ à elancourt par jean
michel fourgous et il a très vite
effectivement avec l'éducation nationale
était déclinée sur l'ensemble du bassin
élargie de saint quentin
il répond à une véritable problématique
liée au numérique et à saint quentin en
tout cas notre ambition l'ambition de
jean michel fourgous et de sa majorité
et de marié l'éducation le numérique
l'innovation et les entreprises et donc
dans ce sens là saint quentin est fier
de participer à ce challenge et de le co
financé n'est d'ailleurs une ambition
pour l'agglomération c'est d'abord 100 %
des écoles de l'agglomération qui seront
équipés d'outils numériques en 2020 oui
bien sûr alors ça c'est en partenariat
et avec l'aide du département et une vie
numérique
la volonté aujourd'hui est de décliner
ce qui a été proposé il ya quelques
années à elancourt à l'ensemble des
douze communes du territoire et
permettre aux écoles élémentaires de
pouvoir bénéficier de toute la
technologie autour du numérique pour
accompagner les élèves sur
l'apprentissage des outils numériques
avec possibilité de suivre au niveau du
collège et du lycée
je poserai la question également à
emmanuel chapron mais alexander de plex
pourquoi la robotique est intéressante
dans un parcours scolaire qu'elle
apporte
alors elle apporte d'abord ça rentre
dans les directives ministérielles on
est avec la priorité nationale aux
français et en mathématiques donc les
mathématiques pour la programmation et
codage mais aussi pour tout ce qui est
autour de la résolution de problèmes
finalement ils se retrouvent face à des
situations auxquelles il faut qu'ils
s'adaptent et pour résoudre un problème
et ça c'est pas seulement
de la robotique c'est des compétences
qui doivent développer dans d'autres
disciplines et en français on a
également des objectifs puisqu'il avait
partagé sur un blog la progression de
tout leur travail tout au long de
l'année donc aussi bien à l'écrit sur le
blog à l'oral le jour de la du challenge
on va leur poser des questions
on aura donc c'est assez finalement
transversale dans tout le parcours sur
le côté mathématique pourquoi c'est
intéressant de rajouter de la robotique
dans le programme de l'année
en fait cela
à guyancourt on a pu au collage en
oeuvre on a ouvert une option et c'est
quelque chose qui se fait en dehors des
cours habituels et de mathématiques ou
de technologie c'est on a notre chef
d'établissement a fait nous a fait
confiance à mon collègue de technologie
à moi même pour monter une option de
deux heures ouvert à toutes les classes
de 3e à tous les élèves de 3e en
restreignant à une petite quinzaine
d'élèves net pour qu'on puisse
travailler vraiment avec eux mettre en
place tout ce qui touche à la robotique
qui est à la programmation et du coup
avec en fil rouge effet le conducteur
tout au long de l'année la présentation
de l'équipe au concours ski robe qui
arrive bientôt
donc ça veut dire que c'est un travail
sur toute l'année scolaire rail sur
toute l'année scolaire a de raison de
deux heures par semaine et en fait on a
cet avantage c'est qu'on en sort un
petit peu d du cadre des programmes qui
nous permet enfin en fait on n'a pas
assez on ne pourrait pas travailler
pendant nos cours avec les classes
entières comme on l'a fait et donc là on
a pu travailler plein de choses comme le
montage vidéo la programmation avancée
sur ce crash
ben la programmation des petits robots
en plus et leur apprendre à travailler
en équipe à se responsabiliser arriver à
tenir des créer un planning à s'y tenir
et en fait ils ont appris à ils se sont
rendu compte au fil de l'année que quand
on est contre quand on n'est pas bon sur
un petit morceau de ce qu'on s'est dit
que bon on allait le faire vite fait
puis c'était pas grave
en fait c'est un pacte les autres et
donc après il faut reprendre revenir
dessus ça fait perdre du temps à tout le
monde c'est déjà ça leur apprend à
travailler ensemble
la religion est bonne on va terminer cet
entretien avec vous parlez moins un peu
de ce robot alors comment vous l'avais
imaginé justement avec ce thème qui
était la robotique et le cinéma
lilian bas le but était de lui faire
faire un parcours et bah ce parcours il
est il est assez compliqué et on avait
plusieurs manière de l'aborder
on peut lui faire faire suivre des
lignes ou directement lui donner des
informations d'avancer ou de reculer
donc voilà pour ce robot le fait d'avoir
participé à cette construction est ce
que voilà ça temps intéressé evans en
quoi ça t'a intéressés d'y participer
mais en fait ça m'a intéressé parce que
déjà j'aime beaucoup l'informatique et
plus du coup bah c'était grave hein
c'était vraiment intéressant en tête de
faire ça et puis en plus bas ça peut
m'aider aussi pour plus tard parce que
tu veux
faire carrière peut-être dans la
robotique c'est en boutique
d'informatique numérique donc ça peut te
servir plus tard
du coup vous vous êtes confiant pour
pour ce challenge est arrivé lundi à
mardi on peut dire oui et non on va
essayer de gagner
ok très bon on vous souhaite aussi bon
courage pour le brevet 1 qui arrive à la
fin de l'année merci alignant merci et
bonne élève de 3e au collège paul eluard
merci également à votre professeur
emmanuel chapron est également à jouffre
au greffe pour saint quentin en yvelines
et alexandra de plex pour l'éducation
nationale rappelle un ce trophées de
robotique
au programme lundi et mardi c'est au
prisme à elancourt pas les derniers à
l'air au tour à cannes dans ce journal
[Musique]
le festival de cannes théâtre des rêves
par la présence de nombreuses stars sur
le tapis rouge certains élèves de 3e
aussi l'institut de l'image et du son à
del en cours ont pu goûter à ce songe
qu'ils aient remporté un concours ou
qu'ils aient travaillé sur place pour
l'évènement participer à la grande fête
du cinéma du cinéma est une chance pour
ces étudiants en audiovisuel le
reportage avec ces images d'alexis
garneau en collaboration avec radio
sensations d'elancourt à cannes il n'y a
qu'un pas romane et les halons franchi
en remportant le concours europcar parmi
dix projets sélectionnés récompense pour
les deux réalisatrices en herbe de 3 i/s
un ticket pour le festival du cinéma et
surtout une montée des célèbres marches
comme les grands du métier un rêve pour
ces deux étudiants en audiovisuel
le festival de cannes pour moi ça
représente bas le rêve du cinéma qui est
concrétisé une fois qu'on a travaillé
très dur et qu'on présente un film ou
conviennent en voir c'est vraiment
l'aboutissement d'un rêve et construit
par le parrain réalisateurs comme par
les autres qui va le voir principe du
concours non plus réalisé un court
métrage comme les années précédentes
mais proposer un spot publicitaire d'une
minute faisant la promotion du groupe de
location de véhicules basée à voisins le
bretonneux les ironman se sont
distingués avec escapade littoral une
vidéo qui invite au voyage
c'est un voyage quand même initiatique
pour une personne qui qui part en voyage
et se découvre elle même tout au long de
ce voyage là et du coup c'est un spot
digital d'une minute dans lequel on
donne aussi envie aux spectateurs de
voyager et de peut-être se découvrir
aussi un air d'autres étudiants de
l'institut de l'image et du son 6 plus
exactement sont à cannes depuis le début
du festival pour travailler guillaume
ulysse agathe camille alexandre et
gwenaëlle sont en stage au département
audiovisuel du festival et grâce à un
partenariat avec leur école ils ont dans
ce cadre plusieurs missions ça peut
aller de
filmer la montée des marches de certains
films le soir ou bien de couvrir des
master class des rendez vous avec des
personnalités connues du cinéma le toute
la journée on a également des
présentations de films classiques dans
le cadre de cannes classics et
quelquefois également allés filmer le
les événements qui assurent le cinéma de
la plage de découvrir vraiment le
festival le palais de l'intérieur c'est
assez impressionnant ce que non le voit
que de l'extérieur à la télé las d'être
vraiment au coeur du festival c'est
c'est vraiment très sympa une expérience
et des souvenirs plein la tête qu'ils
ramèneront dans leurs bagages et on
retrouve une dernière fois depuis cannes
hugo casadamont de la rédaction de radio
sensations 2 yvelinois qui sont à la
fiche du deuxième film de nicolas bedos
présenté en hors compétition
l'un est né et a vécu à versailles et
l'autre est né et a vécu à montfort
l'amaury denis podalydès et guillaume
canet se retrouve cette année à cannes
pour le nouveau film de nicolas bedos la
belle époque
alors ce film est présenté hors
compétition c'est l'histoire d'un homme
daniel auteuil qui veut revivre la plus
belle semaine de sa vie celle où il a
trouvé l'amour je vous propose tout de
suite d'écoutés
guillaume canet et nicolas bedos et de
regarder les premières images du film on
est un peu comme des gosses saint
quentin on a un scénario dans les mains
on est là on est en été dans un dans un
bistrot et on a fait une liste une liste
et est en haut de la liste il y avait
il y avait daniel auteuil avec guillaume
canet non moi je vais vous dire quand on
a commencé le film j'étais très inquiet
parce que parce que j'avais sur
rock'n'roll les mêmes maquilleur en fait
je suis radman et je dis comment ça se
passe je fume nicolas et je les voyais
des fois ça va c'est parfois un peu
tendu mais ça et me connaissant je vais
très très vite dans le rouge
et sachant que nicolas aussi j'avais
très peur quand il m'a proposé le film
que ça se passe pas bien du tout comme
je lui ai dit je te dis il vaut mieux
qu'on reste amis et parce que voilà il
me dit mais non t'inquiète pas du cher
monsieur dream votre fils et moi serions
très honoré de vous offrir la soirée de
votre choix
dans le cadre des voyageurs du temple
moi c'est des histoires d'amour qui
m'ont beaucoup touché aussi dans le
scénario et qui m'ont beaucoup plu est
ce que ce que ça racontait pas ce que
c'est les deux histoires d'amour
l'une passionnés l'autre qui s'éteint
mais qui va se raviver justement grâce
aussi à au feu de la première
mademoiselle
parce qu'il vous attend je sais pas ce
qu'il va se passer
le fond est ce qui m'a touché la danse
est aussi le rapport de 2 de mon
personnage avec le personnage cliente
après daniel qui est un mentor un père
spirituel et qui cet homme lui a apporté
du bonheur à un moment où il y en avait
pas et parce qu'il s'était un couple
c'était une image du bonheur en fait et
ce que je trouve très très beau c'est
finalement le personnage que
j'interprète se retrouve un moment dans
une mission de faire que cet homme on
retrouve le bonheur
enfin pour cette ultime focus de la
semaine sur un film financé par la
région ile-de-france petit voyage en
amérique du sud la cordillère des songes
du chilien patricio guzmán est projeté
dans la sélection officielle de cannes
en séance spéciale
un film consacré la cordillère des andes
cet immense chaîne de montagnes qui
parcourt le continent du nord reçu des
enclaves le chili dans la cordillère des
songes patricio guzmán dépeint notamment
les ravages du capitalisme sur place et
depuis le départ de pinochet
si vous qu'à manche et et loire et ne
m'a pas casser n'en vienne et saigne à
l'islam d'un rocco ex hilton camino
public aux paras béni aïssi targon
n'aviez vous bénira qui s'il a
l'autorisation
etait-ce une immense au talent et à
l'outil leno qui nous est il est beau
finalement après 20 saisons et le 100%
del territorio est propice à ryad
[Musique]
ou à la fin de cette escapade cannoise
et fin de ce journal belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]